tell us the time that you gave up on a
dream
I feel I feel like I've given up the
number of times in my life you know I
had I had to give up basketball back
when I was in college but in this
instance I will focus on a recent script
that I had written didn't even have a
title for it I kind of called it moving
day and they had come after a succession
of scripts that I had written feature
scripts I was still kind of like on that
path to getting my first feature film
aid and and then finally like here was
the one this wasn't this one was going
to be the one that you know I had one
location I narrowed it down to a small
cast i invested i think two years worth
the time all into this one script I'm
like this is going to be my first
feature film and then all of a sudden
you know some things sort of came my way
and sort of put me on the path of a
Friday night before the wedding and I
was at this fork in the road of like do
I continue to write down ideas for this
new script which had kind of been my
pattern for four years in terms of
starting a script you know riding up to
paid 60 or 70 and then dropping it and
then moving on to the next script and
that's kind of relish finding myself in
that in that same position it's like i
finally had it i had completed the
script that was on my third rewrite and
i decided to put that script down and
put it to the side and i decided to once
again start start a new and in this
instance wrote you know there are what
ended up being my first feature film
night before the wedding
wrote that the rough draft in less than
40 days or something like that and then
continued on the path actually get it
done so it's hard to say at this point
in time whether I would have been able
to get that first film done what this
all means I don't know but that that's
one instance of me sort of leaving a
goal or dream behind and moving on to
the next one so at least I can say I did
go ahead I went ahead and got one film
aid and now we're coming up on the
premiere of our next film so you know
one thing has led to another
you